login please welcome to this video this
is some for the penultimate round of the
Norway 2013 super tournament or the
supreme masters how the name is sewn
correctly I'm penultimate rameen sir
eight eight out of nine rounds and it's
a bit late this video I didn't manage
yesterday so I'll do both the rounds
both on final rounds on one day on the
on the Saturday but with two separate
videos so um let's look at round eight
I'm was some very spectacular route and
i'll start with the lesson or the least
interesting game which clearly young was
to pawn off against ronnian we m see
that we had an Enzo and the III line the
Rubenstein system yeah and here black
has got a big choice you can go for
various slides wrong yell goes for the
most popular line nowadays the usually
called cap off variation with v6 cup of
has played this numerous times with
lotsa of success there are as mentioned
alternatives but this is the main move
Queenie 24 should be 70 very normal
developing moves Ruby 19 to 27 so other
things within normal parameters so to
say what can also play an further
developing mafia Bishop g5 one or some
other standard move but what is playing
as d5 the very direct way to go about
that the ideas of black oops accidental
team lose the window
if black can now takes on d5 like this
just in to show if this is played white
is somewhat better because of the better
development and coordination in the
center for example right now the bishop
is hanging if you imagine something like
this just for argument's sake this is
already having a bit tricky for black
now things that not really fit well
together now for example this b6 move
has weakened the c6 square which is some
bit of an annoyance and it's a it's
simply quite difficult to play this
position for example if I said Queen c8
get out of the the deform move like
Bishop g5 intense rook see one and this
is a rather tricky to defend for black
he's taking on c3 which is the more
logical move at first sight anyway if
white now would recapture then like
simply grabs the pawn and white has no
particular compensation for this the
idea ever was taking only six anyway
which is a tactical sequence now of
course why damn place this intermediate
move and there what this black supposed
to play now it's not so easy to even
stay on the board took on f3 this is
necessary you cannot turn for example
use the bishop megaphone for this reason
like now takes on this heaven that's 95
and we have a deadly pin we have f7 it's
it's too much like needs to do exactly
that push up with f 3g tags takes 16 and
takes on c3 this is e cigs has gone
anyway so why takes on c3 first Queen c7
check in between c4 yeah we had some
exchanges and in fact all this has been
played before or more than one occasion
this can also be seen by the fact that
if you look at the clock times aronian
was having even more time than he
started with and to Paula for me spend a
couple of minutes so we reach this end
game if you do account why does upon up
but look at the ones i love this 15
points but they're all week isolated or
doubled like us got on a healthy
structure two islands but no particular
weakness the the real question of this
position is not the pawns but can wide
prove that he's got the better minor
piece sometimes the bishop is so nicely
used on the d4 square and in fact
Aronian won a position from this line I
think it was even against kayaking
against some really top opposition but
now he's playing black and proving that
with accurate play there is not much he
took on a three and rookie one why
German initiates a play on the queenside
based on this pressure however black
simply gave up the pawn and activated to
tonight let's look at this position for
example it's an absolutely impossible
for white to make any real progress Lex
got this active ideas with the night and
white doesn't really have fun
constructive plan to improve its
position I think it's really very dry
and in the game after some further move
yeah they played a fair amount of news
now drawn um it was son it was drawn
here I'm after some samosa we see that
erroneous stolen didn't have much time
spent um it's um one of those lines
where white is it a position to never
lose because you probably em preserve
this extra porn but it's it's almost
impossible to make anything out of it
and so we had this quick draw maybe
there is some way to improve in those
kind of positions who wise to make or
just had more problems but i 1 don't
want to spend a very long time on this
game especially if you look at the other
games which have been simply a bit more
interesting let's look at Nakamura
against them raja baath yeah this some
game really is one of those games where
Nakamura certainly must win it because
with the further victory has some some
chances till 20 to catch on kayaking in
the
andrew job offers in found am terrible
form so one of those games you should
try to win and in fact like a moral
place the open Sicilian not it should be
fine for anything so we get them the
so-called Kalashnikov variation or
improved / Nick often sometimes called a
distillation occur for himself the
player who is now saying that is his own
opening those reznikoff isn't so great
actually but he is not quite sure he has
a reason for that and says that this is
his improved / Nicole again a six and b5
you see that this is very similar like
now threatens to earn fork so wyd
advances and Knight f6 in fact in this
position white could transpose to a
regular expression accomplished with
Bishop g5 this is a main line of this
special account with Bishop e7 take
stakes and it's not a particularly bad
choice but it's um the more positional
way to combat this opening and White has
four fated options of taking only on f6
to double the porn it's a it's a good
alternative though however in this
position Nakamura blade see form staying
within the grounds of this Kalashnikov
variation I have no idea how by the way
why it is called Kalashnikov this really
no no plausible explanation I think okay
see form attacking the beep on and black
advances not much else to do yeah takes
on motion briefly show that like a not
really take here after the capture on v5
it gets tricky something like this
and then simulates it's not it's not fun
so before it's perfectly all right takes
on f6 and back to see to the night on
see-tube controlled southern point e4
square 7 g 3 h 5 yeah i guess this is a
rather normal way to play but then to be
honest I don't really like blacks play
here with the H porn so much and the
reason is if you if you look at this g 4
cancels castles I just put some
additional moves on the board something
like this if you consider the structure
on the problem from blacks perspective
is with this h4 and g4 maneuver why just
got two pawns on e4 energy for this
always has one drawback it weakens your
foursquare this can be a problem the
king is weakened and you don't know
until majan a night on f4 so it can get
tricky the problem is there is an all
night to put down and the other thing is
or a distance it's too far away or you
could imagine that you and I am very bad
with the airless today you can also use
some bishop on this diagonal but this is
not doing so much on g5 and also you
also need to watch over the d6 porn so
I'm you we can desert the square so
white but the problem is the real
problem is where our black spawn breaks
with the pawns on f ing for like we'll
never ever play a 5 simply can move the
Queen to some crazy spot and let's say
here g6 f5 and even then you won't play
a 5 you never ever going to play this
you're also not going to play d5 so you
don't have any porn breaks and white has
got fun right
he can at the right moment play a form
this would be only after thorough
preparation and he can claim exactly
this break open up the a file black hat
doesn't have a pawn break in this
position and this is a serious deficit
normally if you have a close and semi
closed position and you are not able to
do any porn breaks you saw your words
it's just like that because the other
side simply has the only way to dictate
the play this is with a three
undoubtedly white who is now opening up
da phone you also see the camera played
rather quickly and a job off already
close to him getting in time travel he's
really in bad shape at the moment had
something like this and the time trouble
is some an additional additional problem
yeah now White has installed this nice a
night on f5 and this is the kind of
piece you basically never can take
because if you would look at this bishop
the bishop at the moment is some sort of
a sleeping giant it's not doing much but
it's a it makes sure that not an f5 has
never taken so the bad bishop on g2 and
some way improves the night on f5 and I
cannot take it you must tolerate this
night okay now a five the apron was
hanging and white even plays Bishop to
be to avoiding the exchange and later
trying to play a Ford open up the the
diagonal actually teach really Bishop d8
in fact I think that Nakamura played an
excellent game here here very nicely
increased system his edge which should
be six my group a 20 k 2 is a good
flexible move you can use it along the
second-ranked
the main point however is of course to
go to d2 and the tech d6 yeah now
already am in trouble because of long
time um a job of goals Bishop c5 it
seems that this was better to cover d6
evening more like Germany oops after
rooty to and it's it's very tricky to to
cover the pawn if you now try that white
cat num can even increase the pressure
with let's say Queen a one it's a quite
a funny move in ten need to take it's
not quite clear what the black shirt
should reply to that and that's a really
big pressure on like he decided to play
f6 and just give away the poem take
rupee age and then capture them back so
white has an enormous advantage an extra
porn and simply great night g6 and this
check nice tactical play like it takes
this rook d7 and why term breakthrough
in the center so me to Luther King and
now very strong again look to worm f6
the night is so technically covered
because of 37 and what is black am
supposed to play now it's it's not easy
he took on d to bishop deaton so that
the night is covered
commun to d7 and we see that my job of
us down to two seconds it's not clear
that this is the exact on time as usual
in this broadcast founds on icc there
are sometimes slight deviations however
it is clear that now in this in this
time scramble even with the much more
time la cámara decided to make mistakes
and servants it's a it's a complicated
position so no big cam yeah I'm not
accusing him of being a bad play or
anything it's just terribly difficult to
play this position he could have won
with them Knight to f5 now and i'm
pretty sure that you consider this move
but it's not at all easy to to figure
out why this is winning exactly one line
is this okay
okay and you can easily get to this
point and now look for the kill if you
calculate this for example you need to
look all the way up to here and see that
you're basically winning everything
every porn and have winning end game at
the end that's not the only line to win
but it's it's very a very deep and not
so easy to to calculate there are also
other replies for example if you look at
this this also looks critical the this
does the spin white cannot take because
of of the Queen so on what is wyd some
reply even you can take here Queen takes
and Queen f3 just continuing the attack
and this is winning but it's very
difficult for a human player to to see
that there are also this piece of saying
this is the real problem they are always
busy saying yeah so the computer
assessment is all nice but it's it's not
easy at all to to play now can we
replayed Queenie one which looks very
logical attacking h4 but it has a flaw
King g7 answer correct and it's a draw
now in fact um and now we have one plate
be sure to g5 seems to be the
mathematically best move and this in
fact leads to draw look at this problem
is that black already has got some
substantial counterplay clean cakes
would be one check
we should have one and Queen to d4 and
here's the counter play and why does not
going to to mate easily let's have a
look there is no mate this Bishop is
controlling f8 Dwight can you try
various things here but they only two to
perpetual ya hear what he what is he
winning good shouldn't try that you need
to go back and then accept the perpetual
yeah this was some this was a way to to
draw the game however of course like
Amber I wanted to win and it's it's
impossible to play a technically perfect
especially if you have some little time
in raja baath scales you simply cannot
calculate this in the time and in the
cameras case if you're sitting down the
opponent is down to a one minute you
also have serious problems to calculate
correctly and it's super complicated i
saw you drop back to f1 rook v3m he saw
that i guess on now Bishop g5 and it
looks very strongly as we should f6
check as a threat and the amazing thing
is that here black even could have
obtained a rather substantial advantage
by the very cold blooded move Bishop
takes a form I assure you that no one is
going to play that with one minute on
the clock but just from purely
analytical standpoint this check king of
eight this is the big thing you simply
move into the f file acknowledging that
the rook is attacked here so on why it
doesn't even have any meaningful on
discover check and this means that yeah
black is basically winning where do you
mix little it's it's it's simply that
white is busted but he didn't play that
he didn't take on c4 so a matter of firm
of time and
calculation yeah sometimes it's also a
bit of luck in calculation maybe you if
you're lucky in two minutes usually spot
this idea okay it's not a big discover
check and then you go for it but it's
it's just a matter of luck he played the
Queen d3 which is still good enough to
draw black as active enough to to draw
this but the other one was pretty
straightforward night f7 this is some
that again a mistake but it's it's a
very hard to to do a very just
commentary on this because you're bound
to make mistakes is complicated position
white white could draw here with Queen
takes H form and this is an attack that
is enough for for equality this is the
best reply and now the only moves that
actually draws is Bishop c1 and who is
going to see dad yeah in fact that the
toughest try from black swan of us the
Queen sec and playing on this on this
pin this is the drawing line now White
has no other choice than to go back you
cannot go here as this it's nothing you
if you want to see on the water
night f7 was played though and it looks
like a strong move I mean all right so
putting this on pre and in fact raja
baath now plate and queen g3 but the
black could have taken it so it would
have been the best move but it's very
tricky look at this check and here this
is certainly what na kami right in mind
now threatening a queen 2 h8 but in fact
black and simply simply one away with
the king and it's it's nothing really
threatening at this in this particular
stage and black has got serious
counterplay of course white um must be
cautious with with snow moves you can
try that but i can simply go back yeah
now this is tricky because of this one
don't know from you two need to play
something else yet probably here and
dumb it's i don't think it's enough to
white at some compensation but it
shouldn't be enough yeah but ok this is
all theoretical where java force on 48
seconds he played queens III which is
not bad according imeem I'm if you look
at the circumstances and how come how
complicated is Queen d2 and now I'm move
38 umbrage also it's okay here with the
move like or not like exactly this one
Queen d3 can still on you can still hold
this with them quite okay position very
complicated though let's have a look
just there to to show this check here
and Queen g5 is this one one serious try
but here black can
sacrifice the Queen and from material
point of view this is okay for white but
look at the a porn Black is excellent in
this position but no way to judge this
in one minute Queen 23 was really really
good move I'm white probably this wasn't
the best line why probably needs to try
to draw with the exchange here and
something something like this but this
is also um more like White's trying to
hold the draw then playing for win as
there's still the a poem I've end the
game with the receives just seconds on
the clock he took on c4 and this is this
is luis a male yeah check now you cannot
take because of this is even better this
is this is good enough the Queen you
should hear this even this one yeah why
does white is winning you need to move
the king and now Knight e5 and this is a
disastrous now if like takes him yeah
okay
checkmate this is so one line that may
be a job of mist in this in this
position hmm I'm sorry yeah the only
move that he managed to play new 40
probably with no time on the clock at
all wants to take on age three and after
Bishop cakes resigned the idea was to
take here and take on f1 but it's it's
not enough anyway if you look at this
yeah why does having this this deadly
attack in in addition winning this or
here and black is completely em I'll
coordinated and we'll lose the rest of
his material so I'm I think it despite
them mutual errors very interesting game
with little time it's um it's it's
difficult very difficult to play on
precisely in those complicated positions
Raja will simply couldn't defend with
this little time on the clock while even
for that camera that position was too
complicated okay um let's switch to the
next game and this is which one now
they're all interesting
yeah let's do a VCR not against Johnny
ludwick hammer Alan playing default is
varying a bit from his usual efore and
of course this is I'm also one of the
games where Arnold really needs to win
badly he is still an in-flight
contention for first place but he needs
to win this to stay within reach of
coyoacán so especially considering that
he plays the tail end of the tournament
um better win okay it took and Bishop
did to this little sideline her aunt has
played them before so it was something
that hammock unix could expect if he
expected d4 at all but ok BM of course
had great preparation against the green
felt just from the V from the World
Championship match against Cal fun so he
has some ideas to use probably and how
long played the groom fought constantly
so default was not a big surprise in
this game ok we have this line with an
exchange and now c5 d5 took 80 60 a
quick am a quick sequence of of
exchanges here we see that of course
Black has allowed is that his group at
Bishop he is exchanged so his King side
is weakened but then he managed to
attack the center that center is not so
dynamic anymore and white now needs to
commit what to what to do with the
center I'm not decided to push the pawn
b5 preventing a further support of this
and h4 very direct and as mentioned Lana
needs to win the game so play h4 it's a
good way to get some unbalancing
elements of the position and it's also
strategically
if I'd it's not something that you could
classify us an incorrect egg attack or
whatever it's just the thing you do in
this position if likes king is weakened
there should be six was played my black
cat could also think about playing
something like h5 but it's seriously
weakens the kingside even more
especially if you consider a maneuver
like this and probably this it looks
like a position you don't want to be in
you play Bishop b6 I think it's also a
good move that prevents this Bishop c4
things and now night h3 this is a very
provocative move by island of course
it's just saying okay I'm going to play
this I'm going to play this do you want
to take on h4 or do you want to leave
this phone on the board so okay hama
took it i think it's the right decision
if you ignore this pawn and laowai to
just them have its way it's it's not a
good idea take the pawn it also use the
Queen here to get counter play this some
can be seen in various ideas um just for
example okay we can put it on the board
are not now cast up long and what I'm
saying is that like Queen here has some
ideas to support counter play for
example if black would take here take
and Queen therefore this is it's not
great in this position exactly but this
is one way of reducing wides attacking
potential after capturing on F form on
there on h4 now exchanging a Queen's in
this circle grid position it's not a
great choice because white will get the
porn bag and then maintain an X
and position with the pawn on d6 but
this is one way for black to him to
defend take and Queen f4 there are
various ways to to play this this
maneuver so what's black supposed to
play him as shown the direct capture on
a tree is not so great what time is the
best move I actually think he played the
best 10 or at least them a good one he
took on e form black could also consider
to UM just develop I mean that's how
often a good idea but in this case I'm
not sure it's um it's some concrete
enough you can claim like that it's not
it's not bad or anything but it leads to
some attack for white slave this
covering g5 and to know something like
this with the idea also to push f form
this can be an excellent for white the
queen is in a bit of a bad spot here
like if black takes him this whoops this
one enter losers
just one way for y to get a big
initiative also after 96 again this g3
move phone is a problem if you take now
Bishop d3 and this is not done yeah
cannot defend this anymore f6 night g5
and over 6 is also hanging by the herbs
here and then now I get it by the night
so Knight b6 another threat and this is
the quick way to finish black is really
hanging by a threatened to be precise he
took only four I think this is really
good it's not to be condemned and it
took a long time though and Bishop d3 I
really are not displaying the Sun game
in ultra aggressive move mode I really
like it um instead he also could have
played the Queen age 6 which is also
aggressive but this allows the man i
mentioned relieving maneuver now white
probably should try to get this back
let's say say this 987 Luke him and we
take stock black still as an extra porn
wyd got one by one back here but it's
still one except on but white has got
some compensation the deep on the active
pieces or pieces are active this this
can easily join the party it's um
probably compensation nothing that black
needs to fear machi he could have gone
for that I mean wide plate queen age six
and initiated that but it's it's not
terrible for white but then
this is just the the more aggressive way
to go Queen a four and now Knight to g5
this was our hands idea attacking this
bishop taking h7 so white has a
substantial attack what's the best
defense I think bahama played
excellently you played Queen takes a
tube just grabbing it on another
possible defense was 97 you could
actually allow that go also this also
viable it seems this always this escape
edge but taking was perfectly okay now
Queen III of course you don't want to
exchange Queens it's not not helpful
yeah now black gum yeah give this check
this is also ok and Bishop f5 setting up
this this attack on the bishop now we
need to hit need to earn acknowledged
white has sacrificed three pawns its
really three pawns and done you really
need to check mate now or or wind
substantial material to justify all this
um so what is wyd supposed to play now
it seems that night eggs h7 was probably
the right one but this is just leading
to draw it Sam I know it's a tough
statement to swallow but it's a raw like
can take but now how to defend this this
King side there's queen age six as the
big threat and in fact this wins for
white black cannot take on c2 as good as
it looks with the Queen this is not not
defensible
like this there's really just Queen h6
threatening Knight f6 check and black
has no way to defend this you can only
give one or two spy checks and then it's
over it's quite funny Quincy to not
working but Bishop c2 is working because
after Queen h6 yeah yeah this is a
perpetual check yeah yeah if white steps
up here yeah there's a form and you
don't want to test that just have a look
see is there win now like at this can
try white cannot play for when I think
after this the thing is that f6 is now
protected the a black should win here so
why it must take the perpetual just with
something like this you can also try to
run here yeah and I can you go here
there's Queen f5 I don't want to do that
but this is a draw it's just a perpetual
night h7 was a perpetual but at the end
I mean it's not really completely
trivial to calculate button on Play
brooksy one he needs to win this game so
perpetual is not good enough but this is
a serious risk now and in fact in this
position on hammer plate rook to e8 I'm
plated rather quickly attacking the deep
on but with this movie he overlooked um
a tactical IDM and it's this one i takes
f7 wish you played this rather quickly
and this young pretty much um turns the
tables completely the night is also
covering this pawn which is the
mmm the bad thing after King takes Queen
e5 like a black was losing this is the
game and we should have a look at what
would happen if black defense better
rope the eight losses straight away but
he had them various some ideas the best
one maybe is 96 why let's say the most
aggressive one you could also consider
move like a CH five or so but 96 is just
trying to complete development and after
night takes h7 to play then rope the
eighth so you basically wait until white
captures and then play rock the age to
get the d6 without allowing I def 7 and
this still looks very hairy but it
doesn't seem to lead to anything
substantial for white in fact I think
that black now is is much better there
are tricky lines lots of tricky lines
and white can for example play the funky
move d7 trying to lure a piece on d 7
let's say rook takes which is ok and now
yeah Knight f6 check why is this tricky
now if you take it's a wide winning
again with the maid coming or at least
like an only defend against the
immediate made by giving all of its
pieces so this is a tricky so black but
I can't play this and Bishop takes this
even just King takes and it seems that
black is defending successfully he's got
he's got ur than three extra points so
he can also give a little bit material
back at some point it even and it's obi
be ahead i think um islands rook see one
was was 22 worm yeah too aggressive
whatever too ambitious how much could
have punished it really i think with 96
or maybe even some other
but unfortunately for him he blundered
with root d8 and the last night f7 but
um okay if you want to win a game and
you see that they're Perpetual's you you
need to take some risks and i'm not sure
if we she did this on purpose or you
just said okay I'm need to play on I
cannot play a draw here and I can assure
you he's really hungry for winning such
a big tournament it's been a while okay
you wonders I think the Spartan bought
in the event but it's not the same like
winning winning Magnus story tournament
in Norway so he wants to win this game
badly okay um Queenie five what's the
big problem now aged seven hanging with
with the mate basically and also quit e
seven and this is too much e seven and
eight seven yeah black needs to
immediately return the the material and
play on in this position however there
is a count of red route d8 and this also
means that white now is forced to play a
funny move again this one may be hammer
even calculated all this but overlooked
group t7 this is possible if it were not
for this move this would be perfectly
okay for black maybe you overlooked that
i'm not i'm not sure the point is if
black now captures white them yeah it's
mopping up like this and this is
probably m indefensible mate can do some
stuff like this to to get a check in but
it's really just the check look at this
yeah and now it's over i can give this
check yeah like us out of check soon so
rupee 8 plate cannot take on d7 and now
queen f6 this is very strong play
concrete threatening mate and forcing
this yeah ya know why this winning with
this direct attack the only way to to
immediately avoid the mate is to sack
the rupiah yeah yeah yeah instead of 94
this was possible but what do you play
exactly now made on a jade he needed to
to do this so that he actually has this
check here but after this the King
traveling it's again a problem what what
kind of check are you going to give it
to dad it's over again there's no more
checks or let's say one check and after
that it's it's over yeah this is why he
took on d4 but this at the end just
leads to an end game with white being an
exchange add and this is pretty trivial
yeah yeah white can just push the pawns
supported by the rogue and it's no way
to to defend this also now be five
hanging so just this and this and it's
very very easy so a bit of a risky play
by visually but he wanted to win and you
simply sometimes get rewarded for taking
risks a draw was not acceptable and he
played exactly that like that okay next
game is some swidler against Kuryakin
coyoacán the tournament leader he lost
this game against Magnus but I
that is playing excellently let's see
what zoopla is coming up with kayaking
defending with the Berlin he is placed
various defenses against the foe but he
also plays the bullet ants will replace
them the main line nowadays with d3
Bishop c5 c3 adds one of the possible
lines this time not with an early
capture on c6 but with this quiet type
of development it's quite similar to the
Italian game but with the white Bishop
on b5 of course 97 year this is a
favorite maneuver of kayaking see also
place this in the in the cuckoo piano
the Italian game quick 92 g six if
possible and also is playing at emd for
which should be six this is an important
little technical point the thing is if
white takes him like has this counter
capture and this is really a nice piece
only form why probably needs to play a
very etem unambitious move like 92 to
get rid of it so this D takes d5 is not
really helping play true p 1 and now an
interesting move by kayaking d5 they are
designed to immediately clarify things
in the center and in fact the whole
center now gets gets altered why it
takes only 5 and black takes only form
if white would have taken with the pawn
that's 94 and this in fact if you look
at this it's a quite active so white
probably needs to do something like this
oops like this and this is not really
looking like white is pushing for for
something looks fairly solid for black I
took only five and took only for this
looks now slightly like an exchange
French
or some line of the the Petrov where the
e-file is open and players now depended
on small nuances mostly piece placement
this this night this night this bishop
on be sexy successor one important
factor here as a four a five would
really trouble the bishop a bit we will
see thats witless playing this very
nicely he played this first can be
changing and now f6 this is fine and
tonight to d3 this is a very important
not to go on f3 because every it's not
it's not leading to to trouble or
anything but what is the night doing
here it's only looking at those squares
which controlled by the f6 born but f6
had a drawback the drawback of courses
look at this the e6 square so he intends
to maybe use the night in the fight for
e six so this is 1 93 as you good move i
know we should be seven this is probably
an inaccurate move black shut down place
e6 first and push the night backers also
secure some i'm a square on c7 after
Bishop d7 here um in facts will i had an
interesting opportunity which she didn't
take he played something else and really
a great concept but I mean the computer
points out that the media twitch an idea
form was a good move which looks
completely crazy at first why would you
do the atoms give up the bishop but the
idea is the following like this and at
the end of all this you play a form a
five and win the bishop it's quite a
quite a strange line so something like
this is going to have
and here white is up an exchange but
black is very very solid this pawn
structure so as a problem from what I
don't know I mean white is certainly
better but how much is not it's not so
clear to me like maybe has substantial
chances to learn to hold this together
suela didn't do that he p he's certainly
as some of those ideas but he played it
in a different fashion he played the
move a form and this of course
introduces this idea c6 look at this the
bishop he trapped his own bishop and now
a five this was the IDM very interesting
yeah kayaking took it though looks like
the right decision he also could have
taken this one but after this it's a
problem the e 79 is saying it so you
cannot go here because the look and you
cannot do this as well again because of
the ruger taking the night yet he did
Bishop takes a 5 this is ok and now
night see fire this was the idea setting
up this this fork and he'll just
retreated if you take that's this one
and at the end the night will show up on
c5 and be a real pest the great concept
bio base Villa we return to c8 now
kayaking and Bishop d3 this is very nice
now attacking but we has the
compensation at the moment it's not easy
to see the the compensation licen in the
combined activity of whites forces we
see that rather quickly he pulled back
the bishop
and now 96 and here we see that those
bishops are excellently placed got a
great rock and the queen is coming I was
looking nice 96 and in this position
sweet like committed term quite
remarkable a mistake he simply am yeah
overlooked some some defense what you
should do and what would lead to an
excellent excellent play is player Queen
g4 he immediately saw that also in the
game I read some report that here was so
angry at himself that he didn't go for
quincy form the idea of Queen geforce to
prepare this one h4 h5 and after rupee
eight for example you go route Lee one
rook takes Queen takes King 2 h8 and now
why it has an excellent move maybe treat
this as a small exercise it is not easy
and it's not completely easy and it's
not the purely technical thing I'll be
silent for a couple of seconds
yeah white has a strong movie and this
is H form this is very strong it
threatens h5 h6 opening up them the King
position and if black captures there is
some at least one good reply this is one
of those good replies like a sir
basically bastard here you can try this
as a defense and like won't survive this
it's just too much you get aunt or
pieces in the attack now Queen g4 would
have led to an excellent attack it's
it's very unlikely i think that um
coyoacán would have defended that there
was some their other tries or they can
also first move the bishop but i have a
look at this returning the porn and you
don't really want to relieve pressure
but you need to take care on g6 no other
way to to progress here that's even in
another very strong move look at this
position this is strong what's coming up
now it's not a spectacular move but it's
quite um it quite important anyway and
what is blacks idea here blacks idea is
to play Bishop b5 isolating this rook so
if you play him like h4 for example this
but should be 5 and this is really
really ugly you can have I mean you can
fight him with stuff like that it's not
not even so clear but then of course
this is not what you want to do white
here is so strongly and this is the
retreat and those are very often
difficult to find just
to treat get this idea out of the
position we should be five now I can
just take and what is black supposed to
do doesn't have a move really you can
play rook f8 or something but not
something substantial and in the
meantime why does just pushing the
h-bomb and I think this is very close to
a winning position you don't think black
can defend this so Quincy form was very
strong sweetie i played Queen to h5 and
this allowed kayak into to defend with
rook e8 rupee one takes and 9 f8 this is
the big difference he now needed to take
with the Lucani six instead of the Queen
after Queen g4 and blacks now winning a
tempo on the rook needed to go back
gypsy 7 so why does support down but he
has a substantial compensation of course
all pieces are active and it's only the
apron so it's not the pawn that is
relevant at the moment for for
controlling anything I mean what exactly
is the a point A to point doing if you
put it on the board it's basically for
the next couple of moves the same
position but of course in the long term
it is upon but it's not a substantially
important point if you put a porn on a
two and remove the default point for
example it's an entirely different
position because this is controlling
squares the a trueborn this isn't isn't
controlling anything so on let's
continue for a bit so witless constantly
i'm playing actively and probing but um
it doesn't really have enough to to win
straight away is opening the position
further look like it's pushing the
airport
and TM on black committed a mistake the
whole position is very unclear to me
that's i'm not sure if there are some
and its justification for white to to
say okay I'm suppressing I'm pressing
for an advantage or whatever on the a
porn is more important what what's
pretty clear is that the next move is is
not the best one he played Queen to be
six and gave up the d5 pawn and there
must be some miscalculation in this
because after the capture it's really
difficult now to defend what would black
could could have done it could have
could have taken on c4 just being greedy
grab everything and something like this
for example
just one possible line is them still how
to assess White has gotten this active
pieces or pieces are active and the king
I don't know White has substantial
compensation I'm gagra cannot tell if it
is enough the computer is always just
saying it slightly slightly better for
black which means it is big compensation
but very hard to analyze yeah kayaking
played Queen b6 and whiter just took 25
and then I don't know what he overlooked
that not sure this is fairly easy to
assess white still has all the positive
aspects of his position but he's got the
pond now in addition on c6 so we played
the push it back to to d6 attacking here
and this now nicely kept at d5 and c5
maybe this was his defensive idea I
don't know those kind of positions are
very difficult to defend with white
having all the active pieces um yes
witla played the spectacular mood
rookies happen the kind of move of you
have you spotted that it is and see that
is possible then you're going to play it
simply because it's looking look so cool
but he had a very pedestrian way to play
and not a bad one it could also just
take him with them with an excellent
position just for example yeah
something like this should be a should
be excellent for for white ok King edge
8 and look f7 yeah what has something
it's quite funny this sequence but he
wants to play for win of course and
place a queen to f7 now the ideas after
takes the sd-6 and this is some even the
best one yeah fact black who played this
now that I look at it I didn't he played
yeah this was exactly the game I'm sorry
got confused for moon this is exactly
the game i was thinking or what is black
playing now yeah he played exactly that
and now with the main threat need to
cover it and after this we got to this
funny position with the bishop pound
against you can two pawns and of course
this is one of those position where this
immensely important that queens are on
the board with Queens off black is
simply better with two pawns but with
Queens on the board and the bishops yeah
it's it's very much difficult to play
whoopsie eight it's all quite logical
and normal i would say and probably if
it's itself it's about equal
in h-house will I still trying to do
something and here in fact i think it
was in this position or is it one or
move later to later actually Queen d8 h
six we should be six a TI roxy three BR
up c 3 s some is a mistake but um
difficult to play of course roxy to
seems to be better there's a tactical
problem now white is able to play going
to go into f7 if you would have played
roxy to just to show what's the
difference if you do this now FD three
yep this was the idea now you can play
here and actually a cover the
eighth-ranked and the game after this
yeah in fact a three was an additional
problem with d3 black could've could
have fire could have fought at least
like this
this is a possible line it's quite funny
check check
at the end there's a queen and queen end
game with white having a big edge but
you can hang on with blackened fight in
the game flag a3 and this is really
losing now because of Bishop to d6 they
are those kind of ideas now in addition
yeah yeah so you need to tactic here oh
sorry the King h2 and now Queen you want
one problem of courses if you look at
this cannot defend yourself now and wins
so Queen to you one and now King edge
three getting out of the checks and
black cannot take now take yeah yeah
this one is going to going to win play
the route back Bishop f8
yeah and TM kayaking resigned very nice
game bus without fighting the whole time
to keep his chances alive and also
really think that this a form a five
ideas super creative very nicely played
in getting some life into this otherwise
rather uninteresting type of position
with the open e file so I think about
deserved victory here for suitland and
another loss for kayaking which means
that if Carly is scoring in this game
against one how he has even chances to
to overtake kayaking so let's see what
happens in this game cousin being wide
against one how we have them an English
opening with me five take card replace
him quite funny move order he starts
with d3 normally everyone's playing g3
but d3 is quite interesting d 6 a-3 he's
not playing without g3 it's just am
postponing it a bit a5 so black wants to
make sure that there's never before g3
now and 97 yeah this is quite quite
interesting I was really wondering why
not g6 is there a big kind of draw back
this seems much more flexible to me but
down he didn't do that he played um 97
Bishop g2 and now g6 and this in fact
allows Bishop g5 which I would consider
to be am a successful thing on to
exchange this bishop against the night
that controls d5 this is a positional
achievement for white and something that
I would have tried to avoid this black
but okay what happened anyway and in
addition it's not quite clear that it
really am gave white so much here in
fact you could argue that maybe nitey
one was the more interesting way to go
about that getting the night to see two
and support before um in fact I think
this is may be preferable but maybe he
was worried about this i don't know i
don't think so really in the game what
i'm getting at look at this Knight to g5
it's not so easy to get be fine and
without the before move you're not
really having anything as what you need
to do have some sort of porn um pawn
break you played 95 queen live + B form
otherwise you're never going to play
that but now look at this you're losing
upon this even form form for nothing
should be five yeah okay you cannot go
here because this folks to looks but
could take here and now we see that this
is not a particularly great position for
white he really is struggling to get the
porn bag and what kind of idea and
besides getting it back do you actually
have in the position the night is only
two and they now try to activate with 94
and after a couple of moves he also got
the porn back but it's a it's simply not
not so great 22
give up your Bishop and correct blacks
pawn structure but you need to get it
back you cannot shuffle around all the
time I mean at some at some point you
also need to reckon with this or with f5
and so on so he took it and got the porn
back it's not a problem why it is still
equal but okay he's trying everything to
make it interesting with 96 and you for
opening up the diagonal and some
simplifications I drooped yourself now
putting the night in a pin yeah c5 was
played in fact instead of c-5 there was
a funny way to to play pointed out by
the computer and is a very one of those
super typical computer lines that know
you whenever is going to play this is
rook c6 just from for entertainment
value no one is going to play this and
now quit d5 first you think wait what is
going on if black takes with the bishop
it's easy as c 5s append winning now a
truck t6 and then white can actually
capture with the check and now set up
this pin yeah this is a funny way to get
to repeat moose and what helps us like
supposed to do of course you can go back
but then there's Queenie for and you
have got the attack on Iran g6 and
probably the best move because you don't
want them to take is root g six and we
have a draw so a completely insane line
that of course it wasn't played he
played c5 and it's also simply a Magnus
star to always try to keep the game
going and we present some problems but
sometimes not not often anymore
here is overdoing it and just playing on
them and risking a bit too much in fact
him he's sort of drifting into problems
Bishop f8 and now Ruby 6 and this some
methods ok now but now played rugby 3 it
seems that rook d1 was was a better move
after Bishop takes now you've got lube
d1 this is important using the pin after
rook here blackhead this smooth and this
was a slight problem how do you defend
this now there was again a drawing
variation pointed out by the computer
but who is going to play Queen B to naya
Queen takes 98 this is actually quite
strong Knight f6 check and this is again
probably a draw if black tries to block
this diagonal there's the strong with
attacking the f porn something like poop
so not f6 of course f5 Queen B 7 yeah
Queen e7 Quincy 6 it's quite okay for
white it looks quite funny with this
night but the computer just says is
equal yeah it's not the line that
Carlton did find him play droops III and
after the capture there was the strong
move Queen a five and now it's a it's a
pin and there's rook takes d6
threatening and in fact there is no way
to to prevent that what is going to lose
a pawn now which in itself um it's not a
fatal thing but of course it's slightly
disappointing already because if you see
that kayaking has been big trouble and
now you're defending this end game
one down in fact route 66 just that one
de-spawn but it was not you couldn't
avoid it anymore if you move the Queen
somewhere I don't know where exactly
let's say let's say here Heather's
offices though this Queen d3 is silly
you can go here maybe just for
argument's sake and then there's also
this is what I wanted to show with check
and then grabbing the pawn okay we had
aged for rube d6 and we continued here
with the white being a porn down and
okay the question is is it winning it
continued for for a long while now in
the rook endgame yeah there wasn't it
wasn't so much happening really puts on
quite them quite normal play up to this
point um there wasn't really am much
happening but here now it seems that
white needs to be precise and down he
simply wasn't very unusual for Magnus to
make an endgame mistake plate Kingda to
now and this seems to lead to two big
trouble h5 was was better to use the the
H born as a scout to play for example
this one and now important is you now
can use the King to get to get the
counter play so I'm quite hard to
understand why I didn't do that maybe he
feared this move but there is Rube g6
which is strong and which immediately
kills off any any sort of ideas because
white will win both pause here like this
yeah but I can theoretically do this but
it doesn't it doesn't really lead to
anything h5 boss was pretty simple wrong
i'm not sure why it didn't do that plate
Kingda to andrew q1 and now the g porn
what are you doing about that need to
defend passively this is never a good
sign yeah ok let's continue
yeah it's all fairly fairly logical
black pushing is Pawn and TM on King f2
was some somewhat tougher defense
already why this in in big trouble but
you should have tried that you played
oops is so spunky let's just stop that
the window you played King g2 and this
is this now loses by force but only do
it you do to the final trick which is
yeah an amazing piece of calculation if
you see it all the way um d3 and this
now is completely forced what's
happening oops I keep hitting this other
other button it's really annoying so
black is pushing the pawn yeah okay and
at the end there's the f porn now
allowing this kind of things okay okay
yep isn't this a draw okay
check
may be calculated all this and okay
that's the wrong but yeah yeah there's
this move it's now black is winning the
point being that this is the only move
and after all this you lose the Queen
it's a quite a funny final position here
with g3 that Dwight loses the Queen now
by force so one how one is black against
Magnus really spoiling his tournament on
with the wind he would have even
overtaken kayaking and have great
chances to to win this thing but while
how is really an unpredictable player I
think um you have a hard time pointing
out any bad moves that he played in this
in this game maybe the opening was
slightly inaccurate this really am
should lead to something from white but
maybe mindless 92 and so on wasn't so
great i don't know but other than that
one who played a pretty played a great
game simply I'm always keeping the game
going and even winning this this end
game at the end yeah I hope you liked
the video it was a very interesting
fighting round and in fact the video for
the final round will also be done today
just a couple of hours later hope you
will enjoy this you enjoyed this video
and I'll be back very soon with the
final round